si il avait été correct si il m'avait
appelé ou s'il était venu me voir à
l'entraînement puisqu'il habite à passer
tout le monde le sait je me serais
expliqué avec lui et puis on a un seul
resté là mais il a même pas eu ce
courage il a même pas eu de finesse même
pas eu cette classe
pour faire ça alors aujourd'hui je me
permets de le dire vous pensez que Henri
Michel va pas rester longtemps à la tête
de l'équipe de France moi je lui
souhaite je le souhaite surtout pour les
joueurs quoi je souhaite que les joueurs
et de grands résultats mais je souhaite
qu'un jour on s'aperçoit Karim Michel et
l'un des plus incompétences
sélectionnées hors du football mondial
mais ce qui veut dire que demain il vous
appelle il vous dit
Eric Cantona je vous sélectionne contre
la Norvège vous n'y allez pas
non j'ai pas
puisque c'est un gars que j'adore
qui disait que celui qui s'occupait des
Oscars Hollywood a été un sac à merde